on en vient à notre série avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 rencontre ce midi
avec flavie elle a créé en saône et
loire sa micro entreprise de toilettage
d'animaux elle se déplace à domicile et
en quelques mois d'activité vous allez
le voir son carnet de rendez vous est
déjà bien rempli son portrait signé
bombe à gueye et david ségala
ces lieux c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2009 c'est tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle flavie rose angers
20 ans j'habite à saint marcel en saône
et loire et je suis toiletteuse
animalière à domicile je m'occupe des
chiens des chats et des lapins
j'améliore leur esthétique et c'est
souvent pour les rendre plus court et
plus jolie
j'ai fait une seconde générale j'ai
voulu tenter d'aller en première l qui
ça a été un échec total donc j'ai arrêté
l'école et j'ai recherché en
apprentissage dans le domaine du
toilettage obtenu un ctm toiletteur
canin et félin donc c'est l'équivalent
du ca p
alors j'ai toujours été entouré
d'animaux depuis mon plus jeune âge
et quand j'étais plus jeune je coupais
les poils de ma chienne aux ciseaux de
cuisine
et ma mère m'a toujours dit tu seras
toile et tous c'est pas de
compter sept parties
ça a été un peu compliqué je me suis
remis en question savoir ce que je
voulais faire ou pas et c'est là que
j'ai décidé de lancer l'entreprise
bonjour j'ai eu beaucoup peur de pas
avoir de clients de ne pas avoir de coup
de téléphone si c'est flippant carrément
par rapport à la compta par rapport à
tout plein de choses comme ça quoi
me voilà avec mulhouse donc aujourd'hui
je vais le ton de super court facile à
deux soucis de faux donc je vais
commencer par là prétendent suivi d'un
bain et de l'attenté les finitions voilà
je commence à développer une bonne
clientèle
et je suis plutôt content c'est un bon
début
[Musique]
tu travaillais samedi forcément vous
n'avez prouvant la vie perso c'est
simple il faut avoir un niveau de
courage quand même assez levé parce que
sur soi à 20 ans elle n'a pas le permis
comme elle l'a dit et c'est quand même
compliqué de concilier vie perso j'ai
prouvé donc ouais nan franchement
chapeau puis el tarf sigean ressources a
de quoi parle bien de se lancer c'est
normal c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans mais
plus dans ma vie personnelle que
professionnelle
cela j'ai démarré en plein qu'ovide et
ça m'a pas empêché d'avoir les clients
ça m'a pas empêché de ça m'empêche pas
de travailler comme je voulais
travailler au départ dans 20 ans
j'arrive pas à nager
j'arrive pas trop à voir où je serai
dans 20 ans pour moi ça me paraît énorme
vu que j'ai que 20 ans j'ai envie de
continuer sur le domicile mais j'ai
quand même envie d'avoir un salon
à moins donc on verra comment ça va
marcher
d'ici les prochains mois voire les
prochaines années le domicile pour
envisager d'ouvrir un salon par la suite
[Musique]